Chuck yeah man look who I found
wandering on the hallways outside my
office I this is what goes on at your
place of
work this is Lia gatura who's a program
scientist at NASA's Helio physics
division yeah living with stars right
well one star in particular uhhuh Helo
physics that would be our star right
thank you that's kind of our star right
know the only star that really matters
when you think about it hey you said it
the only star that counts that's it the
person who For Whom the sun is the
object of her research yes okay how
about the other 100 trillion squillion
stars in the universe yeah we we inform
them of our knowledge you know and so we
understand them better it's some base
knowledge that's coming from the sun we
got to I got to hand it to you so we
only have you for a couple of minutes
just tell people what space weather is
that's a new term that's working its way
into the public and and I don't think
people know what we mean when we say
space weather space weather is
interesting and it's it's kind of
difficult to explain but think of
terrestrial weather right I mean
terrestrial weather we have storms we
have hurricanes you know we have
rain we have similar kind of terminology
for stuff that goes on in the
interplanetary space so the sun kind of
spew out particles and radiations and
solar wind and sometimes the solar wind
is Gusty and sometimes it's gentle we
have flares or coronal mass ejections
these are humongous storms actually but
all of these basically all the particles
electrons protons these are charge
particles Tangled with magnetic field
start traveling towards our planet all
other planets but we are most kind of
really uh thoughtful about our own
planet and these particles essentially
start interacting with our Electronics
spacecraft um you know sensitive
equipment they start producing radiation
on um astronauts in space if they are
exposed to it we are very careful sort
of monitoring the sun passing the
information to Noah who can give the
prediction and forecast for all of these
we have so Noah the uh the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
that monitors our weather satellites
that's right they are also in charge of
uh predicting uh space weather
forecasting fed I not know we at Nasa
really create the knowledge the
understanding the satellites are mostly
ours and we pass it on to our sister
agency Noah who then pass it on to all
the customers essentially so how come I
how come I where can I get this weather
report space weather report not WEA
report not weather yeah the space
weather report that would be a title of
some album or something yes the weather
report yes I remember that I remember
them we're giving our age
away so uh if you go to the Noah website
you can find that um just do Google you
know I even sometimes if I forget my
name I do Google to find myself the
whole thing Google is amazing so yeah so
you casually said in there that we have
all these particles ejecting from the
Sun and oh they interact with our
satellites this could be devastating to
Modern civilization where so much of our
it and communication assets are
vulnerable in space right now I I don't
like to scare people but there's a scary
s to the sun there
is well that's why we walk and we try to
understand someone I don't like to scare
people but this
is right
exactly you you know what's happening I
I don't is coming wait wait so tell me
about solar Max so uh sun is you know
sun has a cycle every 11 years the
magnetic field of the Sun goes from
being minimum to maximum and so we are
in the rising phase of the solar cycle
right now and the the interesting part
is that you know it's not going to be
out of the ordinary active Sun but this
is the first time in the history of
humankind we have as many satellites in
space and we are launching like think of
Starlings every other month we are
launching satellites right these are all
vulnerable to what happens on the Sun so
so these charged particles interact with
the electronics yes the Machin and
there's no telling what effect it will
have that's right so that's why when you
when when you know it's coming we sort
of send a warning to operators to turn
this off but it's not just Electronics
remember what happened uh last year
early part of last year Starling
launched some 4050 satellites and lost a
bunch of them because of drag issue
because they were like ordinary small
coronal mass ejections but it happened
one after another and it created an
environment you know that essentially
increase the drag and therefore these
satellites couldn't live wait you said
increase the drag so if I understand
what you're saying the more active the
sun becomes the warmer Earth's
atmosphere gets and the Earth's
atmosphere expands creating air
molecules that wouldn't previously be uh
interfering with the movement of a
satellite WTIC energy right right right
right okay so they so basically they
kind of mov the
goalpost what a wonderful way to say
that yeah I'm going to launch here and
it kind of moved it away right and you
thought you'd be safe so right so basic
they were taken out by space
weather we don't say that so loudly
because you know I mean we were not
there to measure everything so what we
are doing is creating the understanding
and theorizing and saying yeah that's
what it looks like we don't have
satellites they're measuring it hey
folks apologies for the interruption but
we wanted to take a quick break to thank
our partners at delete me for sponsoring
today's video if your experien is
anything like mine I'm sure you see it
all the time creaky ads that feel like
you're being spied on malicious links
sent to your email and your text
messages it's almost impossible to trust
anything than you see online these days
and it's even worse that these things
are being directly targeted at US based
on the personal information we thought
we were sharing privately if you're
unfamiliar with delete me it's a service
dedicated to protecting your online
identity by scouring the internet to
remove personal data from data broker
sites and online directories the leete
Le ensures your privacy by minimizing
the trace you leave behind reducing the
chances of identity theft scams and
those annoying unwanted solicitations so
if you're looking to regain control of
your digital footprint then I personally
recommend that you check out delete me
to help you get your privacy back if
you're interested in learning more head
to join delet
me.com StarTalk for 20% off all consumer
plans and use code code StarTalk at
checkout for your discount that's join
delet
me.com StarTalk code talk at Cheo all
right so we are as we are more
susceptible than ever before so if if
you say all right we see some particles
coming because they don't move as fast
as light does right so you can see the
explosion but to feel the particles
there's a delay there's a delay depends
on the speed with which these uh
particles are launched and then you make
the announcement but isn't everybody
just a Sitting Duck unless they have
special protecting Shields and where can
I get one of those
Shields oh you want one too yes so
basically uh anything that affects
Electronics you know when a player
happens a flare produces the fastest
kind of um you know particles energetic
particles right but the radiation
travels at the speed of light right so
X-rays and all traveling at the speed of
light and it's it's this radiation that
essentially energizes the ionosphere so
there are many different components of
space weather just like terrestrial
weather but the difference is that it is
driven by magnetic field and charge
particles nothing like Earth's neutral
atmosphere right it's not gravity it's
not wind it's whole other forces in the
portfolio of physics
right and that's why it's so difficult
to explain but that's why it's so
fascinating to study I I thought the
magnetic field of Earth was protecting
us from all this stuff yeah yeah I
thought what's going on we are doing a
good job that means we are giving out
information I'm so delighted to hear
that is very true very true so if you
compare Mars and our planet you know we
are a habitable planet what do you think
happened on Mars something bad purely
theorizing something bad happened on
Mars because they don't have a robust
magnetic field like ours all right the
solar wind can continuously strip off
now was Exxon ever located on Mars I'm
just asking I'm just I'm just asking I'm
not saying anything I'm I'm just asking
I'm innocent of that outside my PO viiew
okay okay quick before just we run out
of time so NASA has some very good
satellites that monitor the sun close up
right what are a couple of those
satellites oh my God the one closest to
my heart is Parker solar probe that's
the one that moves really fast really
fast and real close so I believe
December 24th is Parker solar probes
perhelion it's going to reach within 10
solar radi of the Sun what why doesn't
it just why doesn't it just vaporize
what you what you make it out of
we bad we
bad stupid question I'm sorry sorry but
that sounds really is that the closest
we've ever been to the sun yes okay
closest that anything has ever been uh
to the Sun the fastest that any
spacecraft has moved because the Sun's
gravity helps speed it up as it comes in
right wow okay so we should watch for
that oh that's going to be a big thing
we call it heliophysics Big Year we are
celebrating the eclipses coming up right
yes okay anular Eclipse 14th of October
total solar eclipse if you haven't seen
it you have to take yourself to the path
of totality 8th April 2024 and then The
heliophysics Big Year sort of ends with
a big bang when Parker reaches oh so
that's 2024 2024 so we have time to to
get tionally ready for it right right
okay all right I can't wait I can't wait
there's just a lot going on Under the
Sun that's what I okay so so when is
when is NASA going to send astronauts to
the
sun oh when it's dark on the back side
on the back side yeah we can send them
at night at night that's
right that they'll be safe if we send
them at night okay Leica thanks for
stopping by I don't know what you did to
me
if I get
fired all right we we'll get you a job
on the on the on the on the street
corner here I
promise all right this has been another
star talk explainer with someone who
lives on the Sun or at least works on
the sun on
sun he wants to live as a star oh that's
even that's beyond where I was even
taking that there you go so Leica thanks
for stopping by absolutely pleasure
meeting you NE grass Tyson Chuck Nice
always good to have you man always a
pleasure all right Star Talk explainer
signing out keep looking
[Music]
up